cette vidéo est sponsorisé par rino
shield et pendant 48 heures avec le code
cyrus shield vous pouvez avoir 10 % de
réduction sur tout le site
je vous en reparle en fin de vidéo vous
rappellerez du sujet global de la vidéo
mais vous viendrez pas de ce que je dis
exactement de danse pas contre vous un
nid contre la vidéo d'ailleurs je pense
qu'on est à peu près tous pareil là
dessus personnellement quand je regarde
la vidéo d'un ou d'une vulgarisatrice
sur youtube à la fin de la vidéo la
vidéo se termine je suis incapable de
sortir plus de une ou deux idées de ce
qui est dans la vidéo incapable
c'est trop dense il ya trop de choses
c'est impossible et c'est pas le cas que
pour les vidéos youtube c'est pareil
quand je regarde un documentaire arte
par exemple bon c'est un peu moins bien
mais c'est parce que youtube en temps le
rythme est tellement fort vers c'est
tellement dense tellement de choses d'un
coup que ouais c'est forcément plus dur
je repense aux coups de fil donc
l'émission avec laquelle j'ai commencé
sur youtube c'était fallait s'accrocher
je vous sens que j'étais assez confiante
ça parce que mon but je me disais c'est
est que la personne repartent avec une
ou deux idées pour qu'il me même sa
séjour et le pire c'est que même moi
l'auteur de la vidéo bas quelques jours
plus tard parfois j'ai oublié tout ça y
est je prends un exemple récent par
exemple la vidéo sur combien de temps
dure maintenant je trouve très bien
un peu raté mais intéressante raté parce
que trop dense trop dense la même un
mois plus tard bas il ya vraiment sans
déconner un genre quand je réfléchis
dans ma mémoire sur combien de temps
dure maintenant passé difficile pour moi
de donner une réponse je me souviens de
deux trois types de granularité en terme
de temps il y avait le président moh
maintes expériences expérience moment où
expérience présente et un dernier chez
puisque c'était précisément la chaux max
et y avait je me suis une personne qui a
été brisé tout ça marc whitten
donc voilà cette vidéo vous ayez oublié
ce que je dit dans ces jeudi le nom d'un
ou d'une scientifique
d'un biais cognitif par exemple ce genre
de choses il ya de bonnes chances pour
que vous l'oubliez et ça me rend triste
alors si ça a toujours été comme ça et
ben oui et non en fait il ya un
chercheur de l'université de melbourne
qui s'appelle jared off qui explique que
la manière avec laquelle on consomme
l'information et le divertissement fait
qu'on va valoriser un certain type de
mémoire et que c'est pas le type de
mémoire qui nous permet de nous souvenir
d'une vidéo youtube alors le type de
mémoire dont on a besoin pour se
souvenir d'une vidéo youtube
c'est le week of memories ok il est
devenu assez inutile à l'heure
d'internet on n'a plus besoin du ricoh
bichonne memory c'est la mémoire qui
sert à retrouver une information par
exemple vous souvenez pas exactement de
ce que j'ai dit dans une vidéo mais vous
souvenez que c'était moi vous souvenez
peut-être du titre de la vidéo de sa
miniature et cetera bref des
informations qui vont nous permettre de
retrouver l'information
en fait c'est comme si internet
fonctionnait comme un disque dur externe
géant et ce qu'il fout d'ailleurs c'est
que on partage le même point plus ou
moins parce qu'on a par an même internet
parce qu'on a et on a chacun nos bulles
faut que je passe une vidéo là dessus ça
fait longtemps que j'ai dit qu'il
fallait que j'en fasse une je l'oubliais
à chaque fois il ya une étude qui a été
faite sur le sujet qui montrent que
lorsque les gens savent qu'ils vont
pouvoir rpt et accéder à une information
eh ben ils s'en souviennent - voilà
logique va pas faire l'effort de se
souvenir d'un truc auquel on peut
accéder à nouveau à tout moment il ya un
parallèle intéressant qui est fait par
geely bec une journaliste qui rapproche
ça d'une histoire que nous raconte
platon dans un des dialogues de socrate
dans un petit dialogue se grattent
raconte l'histoire du dieu thot
ar je vous arrête c'est pas celui qui
fait les sacs tote bag
nous sommes dans les coups de fils par
exemple je faisais des vannes entre
autres pour des questions de mémoires
paru souvent se souvient plus facilement
d'une vanne qu'un fait voilà mais
fallait que la vanne et soit marrante je
pense je suis pas sûr il ya j'ai pas
trouvé d'études là dessus alors je
voulais les dialogues de socrate c'est
parti je pense qu'on va paraître ma tête
pendant tout le long
la lecture du texte on va essayer de
vous mettre des paysages peut être des
petits trucs sympas je savais régal
toile fils j'ai donc oui dire qu'il
existait près de naucratis en egypte un
des antiques dieu de ce pays et qu'à ce
dieu les égyptiens consacrèrent l'oiseau
qu'ils appelaient ibis
ce dieu se nommait toth c'est lui qui le
premier inventa la science des nombres
le calcul la géométrie l'astronomie le
tric trac singes qui ressemble au
backgammon l'aider et enfin l'écriture
gras matin le roi famous régnait alors
sur toute la contrée il habitait la
grande ville de la haute egypte que les
grecs appellent thèbes l'égyptienne
thot vient donc trouvé ce roi pour lui
montrer les arts qu'il avait inventé et
lui dit qu'il fallait les répandre parmi
les égyptiens
le roi lui demanda de quelle utilité sur
et chacun des arts le dieu leur
enseignant et selon qui les jugeait être
un bien ou un mal
leroy approuvait ou bla mais on dit que
famous fille à tôtes beaucoup
d'observation pour et contre chaque art
il serait trop long de les exposer
mais quand on en vint à l'écriture roi
lui dit ott
cette science rendra les égyptiens plus
avant et facilitera l'art de se souvenir
car j'ai trouvé un remède pour soulager
la science et la mémoire et le roi a
répondu très ingénieux toth tel homme
est capable de créer les arts et l autre
est à même de juger quelles l'aude
utilité ou de nocivité il confèreront à
ceux qui en font usage
et c'est ainsi que toi père de
l'écriture tu lui attribue par
bienveillance
tout le contraire de ce qu'elle peut
apporter elle ne peut produire dans les
âmes en effet que l'oubli de ce qu'elles
savent en leur faisant négliger la
mémoire parce qu'ils auront fois dans
l'écriture c'est par le dehors par des
empreintes étrangères et non plus du
dedans et du fonds de même que les
hommes chercheront à se ressouvenir tu
as trouvé le remède
non point pour enrichir la mémoire et
pour conserver les souvenirs qu'elle a
tu donnes un des disciples la
présomption qu'ils ont la science non la
science elle-même quand ils auront en
effet beaucoup à prix 100 m haies
s'imagineront devenu très savants et ne
seront pour la plupart que des ignorants
de commerce un coup
des savants imaginaire au lieu de vrais
savants propofol droit là le roi et les
shows pas là on n'est pas vraiment
étonné que socrate nous parle de ce
mythe puisque socrates n'a rien écrit
tout ce qu'on sait de socrate
on le sait via platon à pourquoi
socrates a rien écrit parce que pour
socrate écrire la pensée ça revient à la
tuer en fait la pensée elle est fluide
est-ce construit dans le dialogue elle
évolue elle est changeante etc
si je la fij je la tue on peut imaginer
alors que pour socrates l'a écrit tueur
ne va pas tuer seulement la pensée mais
aussi la mémoire en fait et ça jared
horvat le confirme
socrates a raison et malgré tout
franchement quand on pense à tous les
ouvrages que l'humanité se transmet
quand on pense au cij pas toutes les
fictions toutes les vidéos youtube par
exemple qui servent au quotidien etc
voilà c'est quand même difficile de
faire une croix sur tout ça alors
évidemment il ya d'autres choses qui
joue sur notre mémoire
déjà le fait qu' on est dans un flux
constant de surinformation une une info
bézy tu es si je peux me permettre
voilà on en surstimulation avec plein
d'informations qu'elle soit utile ou non
mais aussi nos modes de consommation
par exemple si vous regardez cette vidéo
en x 2 vous en souviendrez moins bien
que si vous la regardez à vitesse
normale et c'est pareil avec les séries
il ya une étude qui a été faite à lui
incité de melbourne
on a pris deux groupes d'individus ok il
regardait la même série il y en a qui
l'ont bin djaouad chez et d'autres qui
l'ont regardé un épisode par semaine
à la fin la série après le dernière
épisode on a posé un questionnaire aux
deux groupes
le groupe qui avait bu deux voitures a
eu un meilleur résultat au quiz que le
groupe qui avait regardé un épisode
chaque semaine jusque là c'est pas très
surprenant mais 140 jours plus tard on
refait un quiz aux deux groupes
et cette fois ceux qui ont regardé un
épisode par semaine ont de meilleurs
résultats que ceux qui ont vu une
voiture et pourtant je sais qu'il ya
certaines de mes vidéos que les gens
n'oublient pas je sais pas ce qu'il me
le dise ça est par exemple la vidéo du
népal la vidéo sur mon expérience de
cyborg as mangé un peu d'émotion en vrai
camp
quand je vous reparle de ces vidéos par
le népal c'était quoi c'était il ya cinq
ans genre népal cyborg ma vidéo sur la
rupture par exemple celle sur mes
cheveux en passion mon absence de
cheveux et elles ont toutes un point
commun ces vidéos c'est qu'elles sont
fortes en émotions généralement elle
laisse pas indifférent enfin c'est ce
qu'on va dire je me permettrai pas te
faire moi même le mec par rapport à mon
propre contenu je sais ce que vous
m'avez dit moi je fais avec ce que vous
me dites mais ça me flatte un merci ça
me touche et en fait c'est logique qu'on
s'en souvienne bien parce qu'on se
souvient plus des choses lorsqu'elles
ont été associés à une émotion forte
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que certains
champions de concours de mémoire conseil
d'associer certains éléments certaines
informations à des émotions fortes pour
s'en souvenir
voilà c'est quelque chose qu'on apprend
dans un livre de joshua fouere moon
einstein incroyable ce livre vraiment il
est très très bien je vous conseille il
est vraiment fou j'arrête horvat le
chercheur dont je vous parle depuis tout
à l'heure sur sa chaîne youtube qui n'a
que 2500 abonnés je vous la même
description si jamais ça vous intéresse
il nous parle de deux types de mémoire
épisodique et sémantique
le premier c'est d'avoir des événements
par exemple un anniversaire ou une
soirée
dans un lieu fermé avec beaucoup de
monde de la musique
les gens qui dansent qui ont pas de
masque qui seront des accolades ce genre
de truc gens qui crachent dessus 5
portes
le second c'est la mémoire sémantique
c'est genre d'effet par exemple si
filosa aînés en 1632 amsterdam la
différence entre ces deux types de
mémoire c'est que la mémoire épisodique
elle est lié à l'émotion par exemple un
événement qui était un bon souvenir
quelque chose d'un bon mood vous allez
vous en souvenir plus facilement si vous
êtes dans un bon mood
al'inverse un événement où vous étiez de
mauvaise humeur vous allez vous en
souvenir plus facilement
je vous êtes de mauvaise humeur ou
triste ça rappelle un petit peu le film
vice versa où je me souviens qu'à un
moment il ya la tristesse saisi un
souvenir je crois et que du coup on fait
le souvenir s'imprègne de tristesse pour
la mémoire sémantique c'est très
différent
on a fait des tests on a pris des gens
on les a mis dans certaines rumeurs
certains mood et c'est positif ou
négatif
et ensuite on leur a posé des quizz quoi
et c'était globalement voyez pas de
résultats qui se dégage de ça le seul
résultat c'est que la mémoire sémantique
et décontextualisés des émotions
globalement une information on la
connaît où on la connaît pas qu'on soit
de bonne ou une mauvaise humains
pourtant le truc c'est que la mémoire
sémantique
elle est étroitement liées à l'épisode
hic parce que à quel moment on apprend
les éléments qui sont dans le morse
sémantique on les apprend dans les
événements les apprendre en des moments
en fait dans des instants donc on les
apprend dans le cadre de la mémoire
épisodique
du coup pour apprendre jared préconise
de multiplier l'exposition donc ces
instants d'apprentissage sarko au lieu
de tout focaliser sur un moment on va
les espaces et en fait mais aussi d'être
dans un bon mood parce que même si
effectivement la mémoire sémantique et
décontextualisés de l'émotion l'émotion
est de la mémoire sémantique à s'ancrer
plus facilement dans le cadre de la
mémoire épisodique
une fois qu'ils avaient ancrée on n'a
plus besoin d'émotions en gros du coup
moi en tant que créateurs de contenu je
déteste ce terme
j'ai dit ça là je déteste ce terme
des tests pas ce terme ce que détesté
cette réforme et je n'aime pas trop
j'aime pas trop parce que c'est je
considère que parfois ce que je fais
c'est un peu plus que du contenu parfois
c'est du contenu et jeu ça va rien dire
déjà et parfois jeu j'y mets mon âme un
peu dedans quoi et je sais pas ce que ça
résonne créateurs de contenus jeux
j'entends autre chose moi mais bon tout
ça pour dire est ce que chacune de mes
vidéos doit susciter une émotion est ce
qu'une vidéo que je fais que les gens ne
retiendront pas est-ce qu'elle sert à
rien est ce que ma vidéo par exemple sur
combien de temps dure maintenant elle a
vraiment un intérêt
eh ben je pense que oui je pense que oui
bah déjà parce que elle avait gagné des
abonnés et de la thune donc ça ça fait
plaisir
si je répondais non j'arrêterai mon job
tout de suite mais surtout parce que
avec cette démarche j'ai rajouté quelque
chose à ce disque dur externe géant qui
internet et qu on partage tous et que
maintenant si vous voulez retrouver
cette information vous pouvez le faire
grâce à votre mémoire de huy copine je
me dis que voilà même si on l'a pas
toujours avec nous ça a une utilité
d'ailleurs c'est discutable à on l'a pas
toujours avec nous mais quelque part on
a toujours nos téléphones avec nous par
exemple l on peut toujours y accéder
mais c'est vrai que avoir les
informations d'ansa dans sa mémoire
saint louis comme et maury ça permet je
trouve de créer des connexions avec des
choses ça permet sabu sa créativité
ça permet d'avoir une répartie voilà ça
permet d'avoir plein de choses qui sont
très appréciés très agréable et qui font
de nous de meilleurs humain je pense
donc on va dire que l'utilité de ce que
je fais c'est de donner cette
opportunité là je pensais de créer ses
possibilités j'imagine maintenant on
peut se poser une autre question c'est
comment faire pour retenir les choses
qu'elles les retenir davantage et ça ce
sera peut-être l'objet d'une future
vidéo par une un truc que j'ai failli
oublier si vous parlez du sponsor de
cette vidéo
voilà à quoi ressemble un téléphone sans
rhino shield il est totalement éclaté ce
arrivé seulement quelques mois
après que j'ai fait l'acquisition de ce
téléphone et j'étais assis il est tombé
de ma poche voilà donc j'étais même
sympa au quoi ce même pas une chute au
tout ça ne serait sûrement pas arrivé si
j'avais une coque raynaud shield lino
shield vous les connaissez sûrement
c'est les kings décote mais pas que car
il ya plein de modèles de coques
différentes pour soi pour iphone samsung
one + etc
il ya plein de collection genre ça c'est
la collection nasa par exemple mais à
d'autres collections par exemple one by
one piece que j'avais commencé à lire il
ya longtemps je sais plus que je me suis
arrêté c'est génial c'est un jour j'ai
le temps je permettrai et aussi des
artistes indépendants qui ont leur coque
et on peut aussi vous faire une coque
customiser pardon j'avais customiser une
avec le logo badass socrates de la
dernière collection de fringues
voilà je trouve ça rentre bien alors ça
sert à protéger mais ça peut aussi
servir à rendre stylet ou en tout cas à
changer de style typiquement c'est ce
que j'ai fait que c'est watch je les
mises en rose et jaune et le cadran je
l'aimais rose quand je veux la rendre un
peu funky etc
tac je mets cette coque je mets ce cadre
en deux couleurs et ses parties quoi
pareil pour les airpod l'airpod je
trouve ça beaucoup plus cool en fait de
les avoir comme ça de couleurs non
seulement je les protège
mais en plus vous savez ans tuée alors
maintenant on va faire un test comme le
font tous les influenceurs qui teste les
codes de téléphone est-ce que je suis
serein évidemment je suis en totale
confiance
ah ça fait du bruit
écoutez le test s'est déroulé à la
perfection
allah vous dit peut-être est moi aussi
il faudrait une coque oui j'ai pas dis
aussi ils ont des câbles etc pour
charger les trucs qui sont plus
résistants
voilà ça c'est de la balle donc il ya
sûrement quelque chose sur leur site qui
vous intéresse et c'est pour ça qu'il ya
un code promo valable une semaine moins
10% avec le code si riesch schild
pourquoi pas il ya aussi pas de bpa dps
bf dans leur plastique voilà ces trucs
qui peuvent être nocifs pour les gens
qui mangent les codes de téléphone comme
les bébés par exemple eh oui les bébés
et mange beaucoup de choses moins 10%
voire une semaine avec le code c'est
rothschild
je vous mets toutes les informations en
descriptions et merci à eux d'avoir été
le sponsor de cette vidéo
merci à regarder cette vidéo jusqu'au
bout n'hésitez pas à checker le lien que
je mets en descriptions
pour pour ino shield avec le code promo
etc c'est parce qu'à des partenaires sur
les vidéos que je peux continuer à les
faire en faire aussi souvent et c'est
donc merci à eux et un énorme merci à
vous d'être toujours aussi présent voilà
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu
j'espère qu'elle va entraîner des
conversations dans les commentaires il
est possible au moment où vous regardez
cette vidéo que je sois sûr twitch je
fais un petit live ce soir à 21h30 je
pense et nous lé pas tous les mardi j'y
suis à 22h si ce n'est pas fait et voilà
c'est un truc que j'oublie aussi tout le
temps mais n'hésitez pas à liker la
vidéo et vous abonner love peace
ciao